le 1er avril qu'est ce qui s'est passé
chez vous ce soir là c'est le plus gros
poisson d'avril de l'histoire de ces dix
ou quinze vingt dernières années
[Musique]
salut bienvenue dans cette vidéo un peu
surprise en plus du matière grise de
cette semaine en gros nous sommes
mercredi matin on la tourne on la montre
et on l'a publie ce soir parce que sur
twitter vous avez été plus de 600 à me
demander de faire cette vidéo je dis ok
début j'ai même twitté un truc voici le
screen d'ailleurs de vous avez pas
besoin de moi pour l'analyse et puis en
fait si on va la faire parce que c'est
marrant est ce que on peut croire pierre
jean charles ensemble quand il dit que
c'était un poisson d'avril
on va analyser cette vidéo met plus que
jamais disclaimer comme d'habitude mes
vidéos analyses sont déjà vie quand même
personnel parce que ça s'appuie sur
parfois des ressentis ou parfois même
des pseudosciences comme la synergologie
et ça c'est pas validé du tout par
l'assurance donc ça n'engage que moi
mais là plus que jamais ça va être le
cas parce que je vais pas analyser que
le non verbal ans va être analysée
beaucoup le verbal aussi le para verbale
on va tout ce que dit pierre jean
chalencon avec ses mots et avec son
corps parce que il ya de la matière
clairement il ya de la matière ont
regardé jusqu'au bout et puis on va voir
si pierre jean salençon a réussi à nous
manipuler ou est ce qu'ils disaient la
vérité c'est parti pas de générique
parce que vous les jo c'est une affaire
qui a pris une ampleur incroyable tout
au long du du week-end affaire révélée
par si vous n'avez pas suivi ça a été le
fait de ce week-end un dîner clandestins
organisés par monsieur chalencon pierre
jean salençon bonjour et merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sur bfm tv
pour dire toute la vérité et rien que la
vérité bien entendu mon cher brice en
tout cas merci dehors me recevoir sur
votre antenne posons une question simple
conte que je vous pose tout de suite
etes-vous l'organisateur de dîner privé
clandestins est donc interdite eh bien
je vais vous répondre du tac au tac
non je n'organise alors rien que ça ça
début de réponse pour le pouls dans
l'analyse des mensonges potentiel c'est
plutôt un espèce de contournement de
réponse que de dire alors enfin
respiration alors je vais vous répondre
du tac au tac
eh bien non alors si on peut répondre du
tac au tac ont dit non direct qu'on pose
une question on n'a pas besoin de se
justifier à outrance six mois on me dit
est ce que tu fais des
dîner clandestins je garde non je peux
te dire eh bien je vais te répondre du
tac au tac sans passer par quatre
chemins et sans faire de détour alors
attention voici la réponse incessamment
sous peu
non c'est trop long c'est pas voir si il
s'appelait revente pas de dîner je
n'organise pas de soirée je n'organise
absolument rien du tout au palais
vivienne ou d'ailleurs ailleurs ça fait
15 mois que le palais vivienne et fermé
que mon domicile est fermée entre
guillemets gifi quand même
alors là il va être dur a analysé parce
que déjà ils jouent un peu ce qu'il
raconte
on voit que c'est qu'il a l'habitude
d'être orateurs de raconter des choses
et d'avoir des gens qui ne l'écoutent
c'est le cas parce qu'il est
collectionneur aussi et reçoit du public
à qui il explique ses collections et en
plus de ça il a quand même beaucoup de
dandy demandé des gestes parasites donc
on va voir s'il ya des variations là
dedans mais attention vous n'êtes pas
prêt pour la suite
moi j'ai vu la vidéo ce week-end vous
n'êtes pas prêt le 1er avril
qu'est ce qui s'est passé chez vous ce
soir là et mon cher brice je pense que
franchement c'est le plus gros poisson
d'avril de l'histoire de ces dix ou
quinze vingt dernières années
alors on a quand même vous avez remarqué
un petit pléonasme le physique enfin la
c1 en type l'audace et à il fait non de
la tête quand il dit que c'est un
poisson d'avril je leur mets c'est un
indice à veut pas dire que ça veut
vraiment dire ça mais ça pourrait
vouloir dire ça regarde poisson d'avril
de l'histoire de ces dix ou quinze vingt
dernières années
voilà dix quinze vingt dernières années
il est en train de faire le nom non de
la tête
on a du mal à le croire pour l'instant
jeu d'habitude je prends pas parti mais
là c'est pas prendre parti c'est juste
car ce moment j'avoue que franchement si
les gens n'ont pas un peu d'humour
eh bien ils n'ont rien compris en tout
cas c'était un énorme poisson d'avril
un poisson d'avril qui a en vrai blague
à part le techniques de manipulation si
tenté que c'était vraiment un poisson
d'avril
ce n'est pas la charge aux autres
d'avoir assez d'humour pour comprendre
sa blague mais c'est à lui d'avoir des
éléments permettant de comprendre que
c'est une blague
les images que vous voyez sur la droite
en même temps de l'écran c'est on voit
quand même des gens qui s'embrassent qui
dînent etc
si tu prépares une blague l'intérêt
d'une blague c'est la chute
donc tu prépares tu prépares une chute
tu prépares par exemple tout le monde
caméra test pc
juste avant la soirée en train de faire
une photo et avec une banderole poisson
d'avril sachant qu'en plus et ça vous
allez le voir que après il va se
plaindre d'avoir été infiltrées une
violation de domicile et c'est à partir
de ce moment là il va se contredire
puisque si personne n'avait constaté de
la blague il n'y a pas de blague
si on constate pas le poisson d'avril y
a pas de poisson d'avril c'est cette
justification allez allez allez horrible
monsieur chat l'ensemble faut pas faire
ça je ne pensais pas qu'ils marcheraient
à ce point là
d'organiser un dîner à 17h30 pour des
convives
alors que voilà c'est totalement
surréaliste et là ils essayent de
pointer en fait les incohérences un
dîner c'est pas à 17h30 c'est pas ça
qu'on lui demande
on lui demande de montrer les éléments
disant que c'est un poisson d'avril est
donc que son poisson d'avril n'a pas
enfreint les lois qu ça que je suis
spécialiste de napoléon 1er
que ça fait maintenant plus de trente
ans quarante ans que je collectionne là
je vais passer parce qu'il va passer
deux minutes ou 3 minutes à parler de sa
collection le cerf napoléon 1er et qui
l'organisé effectivement chez lui au
pavillon des visites où il commente sa
collection et la semaine dernière
c'était une sorte de deux demis de
démission 0,2 soit risque zéro enfin
nous avons mis en exergue quelques
tables et nous avons invité quelques
personnes pour leur faire visiter j'ai
fait une conférence qui a duré 40
minutes 45 minutes sur le palais dé
vienne
il y avait effectivement 8 ou 10
personnes qui sont arrivées sur la sur
la sur l'ensemble de la soirée peut-être
une douzaine
ils sont partis très tôt à vue comme les
chiffres changent celle ci c'est une
petite techniques de manipulation voilà
il y avait quelques personnes qui sont
réunis un peu plus tard il ya 8 10
personnes qui sont venues voilà
peut-être une douzaine en vrai entre
quelques les mêmes 8 et 12
c'est quand même beaucoup quand on passe
de 8 à 12
on peut pas dire que c'est pas pareil
surtout que pendant la nuit et quand
même à 6 personnes et
nous avons organisé pour justement la
semaine prochaine et les semaines
d'après un certain nombre de reportages
pour des grands magazines pour justement
montrer les objets du palais d'hygiène
et l'un d'eux l'a tous du palais 10 yens
après voilà en plus il est marrant parce
qu'il en profite pour faire sa pub à
mort mais on en a déjà quand même la
première grosse contradiction en moins
de quatre minutes on est passé d'un
poisson d'avril à c'était la soirée test
0 pour tester les autres soirées plus
tard donc c'est là on sait l'autre ça
peut pas être les deux en même temps
après j'ai été piégé par une chaîne de
télévision fait une rédaction parce que
j'apprécie beaucoup
m6 mais j'avoue que j'ai une violation
de domicile on m'appelle on me harcèle
je ne lis pas malheureusement oui si
vous le voulez bien
juste une pression et on revient aussi
quand même au point il a dit j'ai une
violation de domicile j'ai été piégé par
par une rédaction de journal celui de m6
en l'occurrence et là encore ça marche
pas ça ne marche pas pierre jean
salençon avec la justification du
poisson d'avril
si c'est un poisson d'avril comment vous
alliez les révéler en fait sinon s'il
n'y avait pas eu ces images là on en
aurait pas entendu parler donc ça
ressemble à quelque chose quand même de
clandestins du couple sont importantes
sur les images m6 on voit où des tables
vous avez dit à l'instant oui on a mis
des tables mais sur ses tables il y
avait découvert il y avait des verts
tout laisse supposer que c'était pour
manger et enfin je dirais quand on
dresse une table c'est pour ces pour
déjeuner vous avez entièrement raison
brice c'est à dire que nous avons
organisées comme s'il y avait une soirée
au palais mais il n'y avait absolument
rien à manger en fait en tout cas dans
80% des des assiettes
hier nous avons ouvert le paquet hygiène
à des journalistes etc
et ils ont bien vu que nous avions
absolument pas de cuisine puisque depuis
le mois de décembre je suis sans cuisine
alors si j'organise des déjeuners et des
dîners et des je ne sais quoi pas les
bielles c'est franchement c'est du
délire absolu avec des sandwichs
éventuellement la sq intéressant c'est
que dans dans son agacement
on a plutôt des signaux de sincérité et
du coup ce que je pensais que par contre
il croit vraiment en son innocence
en fait je pense pas qu'il voit le
problème d'avoir rien organiser ça pour
moi il
ils se pensent sincère maintenant qu'il
l'a il est en train de dire non pas la
vérité mais sa vérité actuellement
contrairement au tout début pour le
poisson d'avril ou là il était dans le
mensonge
c'est à dire le dessert excessivement
parce que s'il avait commencé par
s'expliquer comme ça après il a raison
il a tort ça sans grandes choses mais au
moins il est dans sa vérité donc les
plus crédibles
mais ce n'était même pas une choyés
puisque c'était à 17h30
oui c'est hallucinant dans quel pays
vivons nous chers amis et c'est de
l'humour parce que j'avais oublié qu'il
ya eu huit minutes en arrière jamais dit
que c'était une blague
alors faut que je pense être cohérent il
faut bien le dire c'est lorsque vous
avez affirmé toujours sur m6 c'est bien
que vous étiez vous receviez des des
ministres vous avez dit ensuite que
c'était de l'humour on va écouter plus
actions qu'on va les folles regardez
juste la réaction physique de cars gent
chalencon j'ai pas besoin de la
détailler juste on met le doigt dessus
que vous receviez des des ministres va
vous avez dit ensuite que c'était de
l'humour ont regardé c'est l'enfant qui
s'est fait gauler il appelle oui vite je
me suis fait prendre il a eu cette
réaction physique c'est incroyable
gt on m'a demandé et j'ai accepté d'être
comment dirais-je président est ce cette
soirée on m'a demandé de présider alors
que tout à l'heure il disait qu'il
l'avait lui-même organisé il ya eu
maximum entre 12 et 15 personnes qui
sont passées on est monté à 15
on est passé de quelques à 8 à 10 à 12 à
15 mois je crois que si l'interview dure
assez longtemps on atteint les 40 comme
moi je vais faire beau poisson d'avril
c'est un gros poisson d'avril
voilà qui conclut quand même sur le fait
que c'était une blague n'est patron mais
pour les masquer au moins sur les
masques mais moi j mais je les mêmes où
les masques j'en ai plein
sur les images on voit pas avec des
masques sur les images de la vidéo on
arrête là dessus il vient de débattre
sur le fait qu'ils avaient toujours des
masques et tout le temps de masques etc
et la lafa vidéo à mais il ya des images
où il n'y avait pas de masque est élu il
lui même et quand je mange
mais du coup ça marche plus avec ton
idée de qu'il n'y avait pas manger à
[ __ ] c'est chaud hein c'est chaud en
fait et ça c'est vrai on peut on peut
garder ça pour la faune en conclusion si
vous faites par les très longtemps une
personne sur un sujet où elle ment ya de
fortes chances qu'elle compte se
contredisent lui en 20 minutes il se
contredit
je pense toutes les minutes quasiment
entre c'est le poisson d'avril pas le
poisson d'avril avait à manger il y
avait pas à manger il ya des cuisines ya
pas des cuisines on n'était pas nombreux
on était quinze c'est incroyable merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo pensez à
vous abonner si c'est pas le cas
vérifier parce que des fois youtube
désabonnent c'est gratuit évidemment
vous pouvez même activer la cloche c'est
tout aussi gratuit et c'est important
pourra pas rater les prochaines vidéos
vous pouvez mettre un like partager
cette vidéo si elle vous fait marrer sur
les réseaux et me commenter des choses
que moi j'aurais pu rater dans cette
vidéo la ici je vous mets deux autres
vidéos ça c'est le matière grise qui est
sorti lundi
allez le voir et ici je vais vous mettre
notre analyse mais sachez que lundi
prochain je sors un nouveau format sur
youtube qui nous plaît pas mal avec lui
ça te plait loïc ce qu'on a tourné pour
lundi prochain
et ça ça veut dire oui donc ces cabines
écoles donne aussi rendez vous lundi
prochain pour la prochaine vidéo
à très bientôt ciao